hello mina-san konnichiwa and welcome
back to finding paradise episode 2 did
you check it for someone or are you just
jumping in here for no reason
either way welcome welcome back to you
good times were had and we're back here
okay all right some backstory in case
you need it all right this is the sequel
of to the moon it's a game about
revisiting people's memories going
inside their head and saying hey you had
a good life we are two scientist on that
quest and we're searching for this man's
quest what does he want how does he want
to live a fulfilling life we don't know
but let's continue send those pics with
no duck face yep
good old Colin always making the duck
face send her some pics of Asha to the
ones with his eyebrows are on point
excuse me Sophia I think the word you're
looking for is on fleek thank you got it
send the pics where the chin is down
big chin meme everybody hmm can we get
more selfie memes please don't send the
ones with a duck face you said that
already don't send the one with the dick
face you said that already
what am I doing here I'm very confused
but let's go in here maybe they oh there
he is again of course another memory
perhaps another another life another
soul another oh we got it did he just
fart that out all the Ducks are throwing
a momentous I forgot his voice I use
Syria what I'll get it I'll get it
ventually when for each duck I'm not
complaining where's wish there were a
whole flock note
great okay there's another one
so we gotta collect these mementos to
progress into the next memory and we
just got two from a duck that's not bad
I'm feeling pretty good about this are
we gonna get another one my grandmother
turns granddaughter yeah yeah that'll be
we turns five this year can you believe
it
she's grown big so fast I'm thinking of
making my knitting muddler to him really
fir time really flies huh no kidding I
didn't even realize how old I was
getting until I broke my other hip word
of advice don't go breaking your hip
yeah I've been lucky of on that front so
far seriously
I shouldn't even be out right now
why are you right right now where is
this going
it's like just a bag oh loose bones
rattling around in there I tell you I
haven't [ __ ] my wife properly in 84
years haven't given her the bone just
clanging and clunking clanging and
clanging how are you even standing up
what is happening what happened to this
game why are we reading this I thought
this game was about serious issues
wonderful memories are there Sofia and
CF not selfie memes and duck mementos
here we go
[Music]
ah they're holding hands
what's - their call card I printed out
another segment carp what made you
change your mind I still feel the same
way about it but some days I wake up and
see you on the balcony looking out like
that you don't say it but I know there's
something that still aches you tell me
are you happy of course I am
I have you're not sure then why do you
want to go through with their services
just because I'm unhappy just because
I'm happy doesn't mean I don't have
regret not that I'd be related to you
two anyway not that I've been related to
you
not that it would be related to you now
Jesus Christ called them but when you go
through the procedure and live that new
life just hold on to something for me
it's not like that for you I won't
forget about you
it's so sad then can't they go through
that without having the family involved
hey I think I forgot to bring duck food
huh major
well that explains her attitude yes I
told you there was something up with her
you know she's always saying up with she
could always end up with C curb for a
life where Colleen ever seen that purse
it could that's actually true fair point
okay we have to find the memento yeah
what is the momenta then momentum
Mentos never liked those candies I never
understood why they're so goddamn
popular am i right up top everybody
maybe here maybe the bike
okay yeah must be the bike why else
would it be here no then I don't know we
should find out one day so that we're
looking for an object that will activate
the time thing maybe we can just go out
and kill her no all right you know what
I have a weird feeling about going on
that road
what could it be the Ducks can't reach
them maybe if we go back here something
had changed
the post mailbox flowers no it must be
the mailbox right oh my I actually don't
know I'm really lost
what oh there's something right there I
didn't see it of course sorry
sumimasen I didn't see it
[Music]
Hadouken yes there we go everybody
all right I don't it's this really this
is not a puzzle maybe it gets harder but
like
this is not a puzzle let's get real here
what is this what is the meaning of this
oh you can move them upwards I didn't
realize okay okay now it's a puzzle
[Music]
don't worry I am an excellent puzzle
solver okay don't worry um uh stare
there you go you're welcome Thank You
peers for being so smart at puzzles
don't worry this is what I do every day
look at that genius how did he get so
smart we need to stop him I know look at
that 100% wow that's pretty good I know
oh yeah the concept of wanting to change
your life Wendy and knowing that your
partner didn't fulfill you that that's
sad
wait I was supposed to click on it I
can't imagine telling Marcel I am really
I'm happy and all but I'm not really
[Music]
like then you're not happy right what
what just happened oh my god
there is something lurking in the woods
what is lurking in the woods mysteries
ducks perhaps very strange people are
very strange these days that was a broom
reference everybody okay we're getting a
little younger now but not in real life
am i right
[Music]
there was no joke to that what took you
so now hi-five saw someone weird back
there huh did you say that to their face
and hurt their feelings um where is it
they were watching from the woods
watching from their wits yeah and we
might almost seem like they never mind
it's stupid okay ever be honest now have
you been reading too much dusk like they
were static anyway so it's no one
important
hmm well you'll be happy to hear that
well you were staring at nothing I've
scouted this memory out wait what I was
only behind you by a few seconds ha nice
read that book anyhow here's what's
going down here in the kitchen they have
a fight about what we suspect from the
last memory BAM
after that they make up play music
together over there you are etc etc oh
and then Collin go sulk on the balcony
Fiat dude spoilers
and aren't always a bad thing when
you're on the job but here I even picked
up a memory link for you to make up for
it hey look at that and if you want to
see everything yourself so much then
just don't use my unlocks what is it
he's not being honest about he walks
straight through her that's weird I will
be freaked out what do we got
what's the note
I'm not going for you you're a [ __ ]
your old hag I couldn't care less about
you I had a dresser ghost again she
never listens oh that's sweet going
where
another momentum
another mentos I'm gonna call them from
now on you can really taste the rainbow
they're less skittles all right and then
in this room they had the argument what
a sign on the TV
that's Sigmund we all have regrets be it
writing or writing Iran or a dream long
past or perhaps that one special someone
if you've got to do it all over again
who would you be where would you go that
Sigmund curves will give you that second
chance to make things right because with
our hip it's never too late hey we're
I'm glad they made better slogan since
then it's kind of a weird thing would
you would you go through that I don't
understand why would you even consider
why would you toss aside everything we
have for something make-believe I'm not
tossing anything or shine
I mean don't you have regrets - yes but
I actually have respect for what I've
been through here that's like a good
point what we've been through here tell
me what do you want to change I want I
mean there are so many little things
that could have just been better better
and if you called Sigmund what would you
ask for I I don't know what to tell you
for you then the least you could have
done is to make up something nice isn't
it I'm siding with Sofia here remember
unless you had a really effed up life
man I don't really see why you would go
through this I guess we'll just find out
remember
Colin is our client everything else is
fourth I know
fluff indeed all right so now we got to
find the momentum
the Mentos it's probably in the music
room yeah so he changed his mind the
thing is like he would just it would be
like a dream then huh in ending the
dream you think you had a successful
life or like a perfect life or whatever
you would just be satisfied for a moment
look how old the sorrow he goes through
just having to deal with this it doesn't
make sense it's not like you you keep
the memories in the afterlife right it
was Megan it doesn't make any I keep
saying it as making the sense but it
really doesn't make any sense we're
gonna find out I know it this is the
moment we're so momentum usually it's
obvious why can I never find these
things anymore they used to be so easy
back in their day back another I tell
you
where is it maybe upstairs yeah it's
upstairs I forgot we can go upstairs my
bad
no we can't help me someone help me I
don't know what what am I missing did
this is triple da ting me man the triple
died this is the worst treatment you can
get from anyone
[Laughter]
I don't know a Berk of course nope
oh I know yes so smart didn't even need
your help I'm sorry for taking so long
what do we have here the momentum David
prepare it
hey it's puzzle time everybody my
strongest oh I can't
hey the puzzles getting the puzzles
getting harder wait so I can't I can't
but how am i oh oh oh oh oh I II look at
that genius genius pills strikes again
old PewDiePie meme there for an old
Peter pie let's play you're welcome I've
activate puzzle solving genius
mastermind of all things and especially
playing video games
[Music]
what wait how in the world
oh he's tiny now usually you can't just
jump to the childhood did we just skip
his whole laugh
I don't know how this could've happened
but since we're here already try
transferring a signal from the last
memory Roger what Oh what is Oh No
networking we might have leaped out of
the way but the metal path the middle of
the path is still unclear then what now
are we stuck here
beats me we've already
we're already here though might as well
look around
note anomaly anomaly how do you say it
wait we can jump down here Oh what its
guess me the book what cat cata pull
this all the way here right
how very magical and equally annoying
Hey hmm
this book it's not getting wet from the
rain
it must be waterproof huh
I guess it glitches in more ways than
women we got a momentum Mentos moment
and god damn it alright maybe we get
some better clue now what's going on
with this dude requires five to proceed
we found our momento momento man
mementos mamma mamma mia pizzeria
gorgonzola it I'm Kimmy ya got it
perfect I need to be a rapper what am I
doing here clearly I haven't a skill a
talent could be the next Eminem the next
slam shut it sorry you hang in there son
yeah food is on the fridge as always
keep this place and check all right I
will
I'm sorry we have to leave again Kalin
but at least we get to see you today
today before we go I understand you need
to work hard to keep us afloat that's
right it's a difficult time but we'll
get through it and one day things are
going to be all better
we'll make sure of that let me say
you're here ah you should keep eating
more yellow scrap those breads were
going quick for a while I thought you
hit a ground growth spurt
take care son sorry you're watching the
wrong let's play let's get real I don't
know why anyone would watch this
hey there watching with this dog how
cute just like I am playing video games
are you shocked at the voice or pouch
you know be with me at oh sorry again
I'm so sleepy I'm tree flipper for - and
now back to rude dog the red-nosed Corgi
hey look you're on TV say something
alright alright can I show you something
can I show you so free
and he mistreats me that's not how I
remember the show goes at home
Rhoda hmm why should we go in uh I heard
about your cut shot okay
I looked at NASA Corky in there there
yes found him I'm so good at games boats
look look how nasty ister his own
approach hey we got another momentum
that is so cute isn't it anchor look at
Edgar he is completely out of it I'll
let you go back how are you so tired
Olson I give this seems so cute to other
people cuz they just seem being like
chill but when you know the he attack
and he protected me
oh he farted as well see I swore to get
[ __ ] hey we got all the
momentous is he dead if he's dead how
could we be here decades later maybe
it's this train dude too soon oh well
actually I guess it's been a while a
long way but still not cool
hey nanny
he's definitely dead okay he's not dead
let's go and check our momenta
what's happening
what is in this already the father's
memory back yeah Jeff cachinga but Zynga
belonga but no good par wait I just
realized something a few memories ago at
the segment signing house oh here we go
and the bus said he put his best people
on this case this was like eight years
ago Neil but he didn't actually mean us
did he because Colin was originally say
[Music]
wow you really moved up to getting sued
by two IP simultaneously sorry Heather
I just can't have you go on thinking
I've gotten team you could say you
brought that up on yourself no Neil I
really wouldn't say that alright it's
time it's time for a puzzle superiors
solving puzzles this is what I want more
of in life why can I just only watch
huge sob parcels
he is so great at solving puzzles I
truly wish I could experience more
more of him solving puzzles it's a real
treat
well this one is quite difficult if
you're a [ __ ] of course which I am NOT
I am a genius look at that
Oh puzzle how are you so good at
resolving puzzle pants all right let's
see where this goes
[Music]
what the heck is that an airplane
it is isn't it damn that's a sorry it's
not a toad in the back no no and we're
back to old age well Atlanta Center
cactus one three five closing good frac
level three six zero hey characters 135
Atlantis and Roger L to be descending
through you three or one seven have a
good flight altimeter 300 301 five thank
you cactus once we pass well we've got a
nice tailwind going for us sir
now that we're in cruise let's make out
I just want to say it's been an honor to
be here as your first officer under a
final flight this may be my first time
as a first officer but I won't let you
down yeah it's all good
sorry dude rather poetic really passing
the baton and all but you should know
they just be crazy and as my co-pilot
there's only two things I ever want to
hear from you two things sir yep there
yes captain
and landing gear down you're funny sir
what did I just say yes captain
yeah of course I'm just messing with it
just reminded me of back when I did my
first flatters first officer that's oh
man my captain then was a crazed crazy
mess yes captain
hmm you know I just said I was kidding
right
yes captain okay hey I'm gonna let my
wife and son come in and sit for a bit
if you don't mind it's my last flight
after all they're not gonna get this for
you again
yes captain Wow Irene could you bring my
family in thank you
maybe now we get a taste of what they
meant with just better flight
regulations were still so chilled back
in the day huh
my my my oh my god my brain just went
immediately to 911 memes and I hate how
the Internet has done that to me
so what did you say one last round is it
alright with management
I already approved special location and
all you heard him go gaga
[Music]
French accent I thought it was the some
random guy
so you were gonna miss the fuse from the
big birds sure but it's not like I'm
giving up the sky oh don't you go
renting those small planes I don't trust
you flying them speck it speaking of
away earth I wish they gave you a bigger
plane for the last flight of your career
like one of those monster double deckers
I asked for this particular one myself I
had my first flight with airline in this
head was a different time back then a
time with lots of peanuts I miss him so
much
your now you know Dave all these yes a
flame and you never told me why you
choose to be a pilot in the first place
all right haven't huh I like the music
don't tell your mother but it was to
impress a girl yeah
did it work sure I guess oh please with
the way your father acted I doubt he
dated anyone at all when we met shots
fired
dead hey hey now fear don't go spreading
false rumors in front of our son I'll
have you know that that was quite the
stud back in the day yeah captain just a
reminder that we're on the record for
the black box
ah thanks for that reminder let the
record show that my biceps are out of
this world
no no they really hurt oh but they are
when I pulled that yoke on don't take
off earlier
I practically lifted the entire plate
off the graph isn't that right Peyton
yes captain
yeah well let me tell y'all a story
about this one time involving a jar of
pickles okay we we need to maintain a
sterile cockpit for landing let's let's
get you two back to your seat off you go
now shoo shoo sir we're not landing for
another couple hours miss please I know
okay so are you coming with or why now I
like this view I thought you were a crew
phobic only when I'm not inside a plane
how about you go wrap up this memory and
I'll join you shortly after but you're
serious it's in a loop yeah but the
picture from this seats angle is just
absolutely divine
in fact I pity you or anyone who can't
see the way they were
Thanks thanks game maker don't give me
that cabbage what this is when we landed
yeah thank you for the lovely flight sir
chase hope you have a nice day hello
little one hope you enjoyed that the
Lightning shot uh yeah sorry it was a
little rough not one of my better
landings the wind was ok so he just
wants to change small stuff that could
be better like his last flight he got a
bad landing I kind of get that to be
honest
we need one more though I wonder what
I'm missing it must be up here
did I just glitch out the game or
something no we haven't found the
memento yet maybe it's outside the plane
how it is ah
a fellow cellist huh is that how you say
it I don't know here let me get that for
you
I guess they have special cargo thank
you sir
yay are you gonna show up ha
not really my wife is the real musician
of the family beautiful blue instrument
though loved playing it as a kid as a
kid but he stopped in me
then we'll grin of letting go of an
instrument that's the memento okay oh
[Music]
sorry
and now the favorite time of the year
PewDiePie solving puzzles ah ah so
interesting when you saw those boards I
just want to see you saw more parcel hey
they're so great wow you solved this one
so fast I'm so impressed how do you do
it don't worry about it okay a great
magician never tells his secrets just
like a great Rick and Mona faint never
tells how he got that IQ so high
activate
SAP dude I was just about to
[Music]
they really wrap things up so nicely
okay we're back as a kid now that's a
bit unexpected uh oh he did mention
being a kid how did we skip to the
childhood memories with him and that's
time the memento isn't even that back is
there something wrong with the Machine
Neal huh it's not the machine at least I
don't think it is well I guess at least
we know that we can go back now
what's this hope this doesn't interfere
with finishing this job relax
I'll manage okay
[Music]
get hearing to me get used to it loved
playing cello as a kid my ass liar liar
pants on fire
well you belong at a grade school your
child is Japs aside even on an unrelated
note this place kind of makes me feel
like I'm on the set of some indie French
fare what about this possibly makes you
feel that way I don't know
just a feeling is this a reference to
something oh okay well if you wanted
something in you could've landed Paley
well maybe he's still enjoyed playing it
love the music very funky funky is not
the right word doesn't matter a back hey
don't push
I called them so violent it's so like to
carry I'm gonna get the flu if it's my
baby [ __ ] I got the cello what up
what up pimps need his facepalm
[Music]
okay so what if it's heavy alright if he
wanted to bring a machine gun to school
no not that joke did you see that
is he carrying that thing or is it
carrying him looks like just a floating
case from behind guess he was like me a
tiny boy in school
yep that's right I matured late in
school alright it's not my fault and
look at me now I'm a big man now so be
quiet huh I have a feeling these aren't
exact replicas from the actual setting
it's as if memories to quite they create
a libertine mixing things that as in the
isn't the machine built with public
domain data stabilizer to prevent this
yeah but I may be broken
maybe you're the speech specialist yeah
better
have a look afterward maybe he got his
own memories confused maybe he lived a
really good life in this guy sure it
takes creative Liberty with his memories
okay yay oh because the trees are mixed
with the I didn't even notice seesaw
took me so long to learn what this is
calling english in sweden we just call
it goomba which makes a lot more sense
wow this is awkward to watch everybody
why do we get all these losers no
clients maybe cuz you're here [ __ ] Oh
bazinga well that's a nice compliment
and a Gauss law for magnetism what
there's a shovel here that I really want
to press but I guess I can't
what is happening we need one more
momento
Mentos or is it I must have missed
something what it was missed the last
one
it's not because he I did but help wish
you could run in the game it's kind of
annoying going back and forth here we go
this must be it
what's he doing
counting dirt I guess is the classroom
nice classroom Colin is that a teddy
bear
what the hell're Colin the answer is C
none either [ __ ] I'll ask you again what
is the radius of this circle where's
your hello Connie
go stand out in the house me and
literally at school thinking about video
games oh boy I can't wait to go home and
play [ __ ] this
and Here I am I think I saw something on
the wall back there stay obviously hey
it's it's a it's a it's a hole in the
wall that could be our ticket Eddie all
right I think we could reach it if we
just now I got this let me find a way
what all right now to watch this is that
African one wait you didn't disable that
mobile Arius teacher's desk Asst what in
the world is happening and this is so
weird dude reset okay first of all
disable reactive interactivity before
you pull that stop and second of all
that's not even how the spill guts yeah
this did you see that thing flat they
sure did you pull a idiot okay alright
glad we did that everybody bazinga
bazinga bazinga and hello
what nothing I guess I was suspecting
you to start seeing dumb things again oh
I didn't don't you worry ever do you
know how draining it is to unleash a
Kamehameha and a Hadouken simultaneously
I mean I know I'm a pro but even I need
my beauty sleep oh it's the favorite
time of her solving puzzles how how does
he do it so well he must have at least a
million billion gazillion enqueues look
at him gut like oh my god he's so fast
and Mayor say he's so handsome this is
why I love his let's place [ __ ] I wanted
I wanted them all in that one but I
guess you know what you can't have a lei
look at this look at this bad a turbo as
I like to say that's right we unlock the
watch momento everybody high five there
you go
don't you feel better now here we go
next memento please thank you
here we are everybody and a new place um
are we back at the old HP really game
well it sure looks like it
ah sure them shirt about and here it is
the perfect retirement apartment that's
such a lame thing here's where you will
die everybody with we sure her ok I
think I got it figured out hmm I mean we
haven't just been jumping back and forth
randomly right there's a pattern to it
let's see please explain with all your
other patient's we began from the most
recent winning Radley trade backwards
anyway thief I did indeed start like
date and I'm turning into Sayuri pretty
face everything means you get near me
but then we same hey getting chilly
another way to the alias exceeds my
memory so we clearly and we're the
guinea pig to the early change where we
lived I've dinged it earlier in the game
really vary in wins mates ATT moving
batteries this
Jassi me Peter panda batik a happy
it's amethyst I'm being pulled in
spreading toward the gravitates an
identity that gravitates in the center
huh
inappropriate inappropriate context for
physics aside what do you think is
cursing this some oh so deep event of
melodramatic eggs that traumatized our
fine gentlemen eating you repeating me
bereaved ACP I can't help me maybe it's
something else something else what could
be here other than memories like I said
I don't know it's just that week we've
seen a lot of patience
and there's never been a memory need
that standings alright I guess at least
this one isn't routine then we'll see
whoa what just happened my god Fred good
ol Fred everybody remember Fred I
remember Fred never forget II one
bedroom with balcony and there are souls
an attic for sure rich how often do you
find addicts in the apartment huh not to
mention the lake beam
I thought the lake is on the other side
of the building though yeah but this
unit is on edge you can see it if you
hold out a mirror from the balcony
how lovely here have a brushing and this
is the Quechan if you pay attention to
the walls you'll notice that it hasn't
had even one fire accident Wow of course
if it had the whole place would have
surely burnt down being an apartment at
all great I mean of course it won't
happen because you all seem like careful
parks right I guess what I'm saying is
fire safety is very important
look I'm sorry I'm just really new at
this no one has died in this house how
about that guys you're gonna be the
first one to die okay alright okay we
need three more uh-huh the brochure here
the air inside here it's Fred what's he
gonna say next you're a magician right
this room is perfect for performances
there's a very little room for an
audience though so you'll probably be
playing alone loser which is kind of sad
but I digress
[Music]
I also began with the stairs y'all seem
to have rocket hips so no problem here
I've seen you in the bedroom I'm a [ __ ]
oh I can't wait to see you I set up
cameras everywhere why is my mind doing
the worst things on old times I hate it
it's a condition people don't realize
the balcony you said yep it's got a
great view and given how high it is
you can certainly fall and I mean yes
balcony it has that Wow
so I think the second last one is here
and then the last one would be in the
balcony so we'll go ahead and attic is
in an apartment isn't it amazing
I think the floor is otherwise reserved
for heating and utility units for the
building as something in the building
explodes I guess it probably hit pretty
close dude Fred stop okay I'm trying to
feel spooked about the memory leap thing
but this isn't helping trying not to
feel spooked probably is what is in my
mind just skips ahead sometimes and fill
in the gaps also a condition that I
can't help so don't judge me the layout
of this house is so strange just make
any sense there there and as you can see
this is why they call it Lakeview
residue we hope you enjoyed your stay at
Lake be visiting I mean you can
literally see you can't literally see
because the lakes behind us on the other
side but if you extend your head after
packing it to the left you might be able
to see a bit of it don't though you'd
fall out okay and we go
good old Fred everybody I'm starting to
see calling this perspective you know
he just had a very mediocre life so
where do you think well it's nice and
quiet I like it
me too but I would have liked it better
if you just didn't talk Fred yeah that
really didn't help at all
if you weren't my cousin's friend's
brother we would have walked out by now
more like ran out I'm sorry guys
I'm not good at Sam's so I'm sorry to be
blood but are you going to take it
because there's a deposit fee you see
which technically I could elope with but
I promise I stop talking we'll take it
mm-hmm Oh Fred you did it your dingus
thank heavens my wife's gonna murder me
if I didn't make a stand by this man
there carrots
I want away I guess he just folded it
what's this oh well if I'm guessing
right it's a memento
mamaan moment begins a memento it's kind
of hard that it came to be without
seeing huh in any case at least it's
convenient I didn't see any other way
out of the space it's time for the
favorite moment of me solving puzzles
everyone watch me sub but no this is
impossible I can't move any other way
than this this is crazy what could I
possibly do differently for real I can't
move
[Music]
well I guess we're just not solving
anything oh I can't move the middle I
didn't see that okay
wow that changes a few things Josh Akash
boom boom boom boom
I want you in my broom and spend the
night together and now until forever
boom boom boom boom
what is wrong with me Jesus Christ let's
go
[Music]
hey we're look we're back maybe I can
give you the kid the saiary voice what
do you think of that let's jump off this
balcony again slingback in huh yep
your theory still checks out okay
let's plays [ __ ] what bets and what's
causing is anomaly of curse your guess
is versus man I'll get a wife
dibs on first guests then bet you 10
bucks it's about a girl suddenly a
romantic aren't you now just the fact
that with these things
it's always about some good not
everything is about some girl meal
besides I think we've seen enough from
his own memories to say he's happily
married it place their bets in the
comments
Oh 10 bucks to me I didn't say it out
loud because you know what you need
yes it's perfect
[Music]
I see you standing if they make their
DVD what do you have it's taking me
it's a aureus a Chad there you do got a
mean that's why he's so fascinated with
the backhoe neat uh you have named he
Colin what I said my name is Colin hey
you're calling white and to speak what
no I let me just ah hold on I'll be
right back
he's gonna throw his dog across oh my
god don't do that don't do that corgis
can't fly it's their main weakness this
is why you need a hook like like me
hello everybody it's your favorite
segment of the show wish me did you miss
me of course you do how could you know
it makes me
Wow this video is really boring hurts
why is nothing happening did you just
get a memento from doing nothing so
again please okay I'm trying it's a
route okay great
doesn't seem like he's playing with it
much poor oneth
yeah yeah just like me pouch hey panty
pay attention to me players I'm like so
high right now guys
[Music]
hey I'm gonna throw this paper plane
over there oh I can do his voice that's
perfect though it's good idea
I wrote stuff on it just so just catch
it okay I was gonna say just be okay
okay here it goes
[Music]
great color
yeah that's not working
damn kid has no respect for the last of
basics he's like 9 dude he is a reed
you need to concentrate okay just keep
your eye on me and through his hair is
he King III hate Denise I'm sitting
Jerry I believe in you okay okay I can't
do this
they record
[Music]
oh my god how about cat I can't look
is she gonna do it that's not funny
you came through against the green
feeling I'm gonna have a dream do you
think I'm going inside okay Dickie or
they have tires on their balcony so he
can't lead me I thought you didn't hear
ya I think it should be seen you in the
way to ski so what does that have to do
with him he raped sorry I rather
terribly yeah I mean a goat even with
just a crisis beefy news the private
school yep yep yeah I can see how rich
you are from all the tires you're
collecting and bag of potatoes lucky
well cuz it's an explosive in cash money
and staff Oh people they don't stare be
there though
they are no I'm just trying to make if
you're better
hey that's what difficult to get Knicks
team why can they let you see me you're
just the right amount of Dean what's
that supposed to mean
BC have you heard about the bear attacks
into it no I've only seen Badgers
watches your hair I knew I didn't hear
anything either
but that's why I'm suspicious it's a
little teacake way anyway we practically
go to the theme right right it'd be a
good to take together I guess so
that's so cute a childhood romance
well what was it hmm she just ran back
in when they came in I had signed up I'm
coming for kids to be scared of parents
back when I was young I knew a kid who
had a scary mother saw her spanking him
with a spatula once never ate her
brownies every day hmm
it's getting interesting this is the
memento isn't it we found their memento
everyone Oh another clack don't you dare
do anything I'm getting this one let me
at least take it up the Wi-Fi yeah sorry
I know just don't even if it's it's not
even that high we don't need to take it
to you Oh easy nerve why don't we wear
our weird icky we need two more mementos
how what's been here
okay all right looks like it's time for
me again stop terrorizing me on the
upside I wish I had the TV all to myself
when I was kid you and BrewDog that's
not a momento there's one on the TV
though isn't it
today it's classic Erica take it easy
busy baby bleep me me me me me me me me
me why can't we have a single jingle
this catchy one can only dream kerman
ethnic scaling we paid to get baby hold
on I I kind of want to say in watch this
what what is this what is that look what
is that what is that what is that he's
playing in the bathroom why are you
practicing in the bathroom because the
bathroom reverbs makes us sound awesome
of course you sure seem knowledgeable
back when I played the triangle I did it
of the time oh wow he's quite talented
it's almost better than me at the triad
go okay Wow not even family bathroom
Reba could save that crap all right we
got all the mementos and I believe this
is the last one for the day the story
cacao cacao cacao is getting cacao
interesting
I'm curious more and more but the
favorite segment of the day some blanks
helps to remember some it helps to
forget what oh I see
all right hey look at that okay all
right now we need to keep them on
different time names there we go
are they old they're all glasses King do
that then how is he so smart that passes
everyone is still trying to understand
that was that no no more oops I made a
mistake here we go everybody
hundred percent why our purse you're so
good again how you get so good and how
you get such excellent dog I don't know
it again I just don't know Wow
I must say I really enjoyed this episode
punch so much so that I will press like
on this video right now
you're welcome everybody and you should
do the same pause pause for the love of
God you can't pause
again I guess I gotta read this people
are look at fire now ours for your last
performance here I'm not nervous it's
just I played in this theater for so
many years it feels strange to just have
this be the last well you never know we
can always visit this place isn't going
anywhere I saw what you were gonna play
by the way not my most virtuous piece
huh well I kind of like that one but I
thought you didn't
I guess it's grown on me I know it just
a little hey we still got some time
before the concert starts right go get
your cello and come play with me for a
bit that'll help me calm my nerves I
thought you weren't nervous
besh was lying
beautiful music okay that will be it for
this episode thank you so much for
joining me on this I hope you enjoyed it
I had a lot of fun and I'll see you
tomorrow with another one stay a supress
[Music]